hbo's new darling now that game of
thrones is no more succession has
basically everything the fantasy series
had
apart from dragons and disappointing
endings the comedy drama is packed full
of intrigue backstabbing and smooth
dialogue and it seems like no one can
stop talking about the roy family
including us in this video we're going
to take a look at 25 or so things that
you might have missed including moments
of foreshadowing improv behind the
scenes details and of course hidden
easter eggs so let's go oh and uh
spoiler warning there will be heavy
season one to three spoilers in this
video all right let's start off with the
very end of season three shall we as you
know the show is rife with backstabbing
plotting and betrayal and of course the
end of season 3 is no different with tom
turning on kendall roman and even his
own wife shiv doing a deal with the
devil and getting a good ol slap on the
back in return in this moment tom
basically becomes the favored pseudo-sun
by helping logan nix the trio's plan to
use the super majority clause to prevent
the company being sold from underneath
them this may have been a shocking
betrayal in the moment but we probably
should have seen it coming okay
as the outsider thomas always had more
to prove which means that he had to make
the biggest plays for example in season
3 episode 3 when he offers himself up to
be the fall guy if the doj needs to
imprison someone in the waystar suit
logan impressed by his loyalty gives him
a big ol slap on the back just like he
does at the end of season 3. other clues
include tom's hunch where he gives his
f-bomb-filled piece of advice to kendall
hinting where his true alliances lie the
fact that logan knew about the secret
tea party with donutgate indicating that
he had a spy in episode 7 of season 3
logan squeezes tom on the arm and
whispers i'll remember referring to
tom's act of loyalty and finally tom's
nero and sporus story that he tells to
greg effectively sums up their
relationship and tom's overarching plan
i don't know about you but i'm looking
forward to seeing emperor tom in action
in season 4 although if word on the
street is to be believed it will likely
be the show's last the show makes plenty
of references to a number of classic
plays such as king lear and oedipus rex
but the show also makes a reference to
the great gatsby with the character of
kendall for example all of the pool and
drowning imagery now while kendall
didn't die like gatsby after his
near-death experience in a pool the
moment has been foreshadowed throughout
the course of the show and that episode
in particular is rife with images of
water season two begins with kendall
slowly rising out of the water which is
effectively the opposite of the moment
in season three when he slowly descends
into it other moments include the moment
where he gets into a car crash with a
caterer at shiv's wedding with the car
sinking to the bottom of a bog the
moment where kendall has a panic attack
and an empty bath and logan's line in
season one where he says
i don't want him showing up dead at the
bottom of some french expletive
deleted's pool while kendall may have
escaped his watery grave for now don't
be too surprised if he finds himself
there once again before the show wraps
up
okay
as we mentioned one of the biggest
inspirations for succession is the
shakespearean play king lear which
centers on the mythological lair of
britain the play focuses on the idea of
succession and what happens to the
patriarch king lear after he
relinquishes his power and land to two
of his daughters and the play has been
inspiration to many notable works over
the decades such as akira kurosawa's
epic ran succession references many
elements of the plot in the show but the
most direct reference is the name roy
which is derived from the old french
word rey meaning king on the subject of
origins of names logan means hollow take
from that which you will shiv means pure
roman means strong and powerful conor
means wise and kendall
means valley of the river kent yep i was
expecting more from that one too now
going back to that season 3 finale now
for the promotion of the most recent
season hbo released a number of posters
with a line drawn between kendall and
logan with the rest of the characters
lining up behind one or the other with
each poster having different family
members on different sides every time
however there was one that did show how
the final battle lines were drawn with
tom and greg behind logan while the
others lined up behind kendall
succession may have some a-listers
behind it with adam mckay and will
ferrell serving as producers for the
show but the creator jesse armstrong has
some more humble roots with him writing
on the show thick of it as well as being
co-creator for british show's fresh meat
and my favorite comedy series of all
time peep show the comedy that follows
characters even more dysfunctional than
the one seen in succession jeremy
usborne and mark horrigan or mark
croregan as it says on his book business
secrets of the pharaohs still holds a
place in many people's hearts myself
included and a number of die hard fans
who love the show more than mark loves
johnson took to reddit to share some
peep show easter eggs they noticed in
succession one of the men from the
independent investigative committee who
interviews tom is called stefan strauss
which is the same name as the german ceo
of the fictional company jlb and peep
show the techno gatsby line from
succession is a play on jez's techno
gandhi line and peep show and tom saying
one of those urban things is a play on
another one of jez's lines also jesse
armstrong's production company is called
project zeus which is another reference
to the almighty peep show now despite
some of the dialogue having hidden
meanings given armstrong's background in
comedy a lot of the dialogue in
succession is unsurprisingly improvised
speaking on his process armstrong said
having them all around a dinner table
and having a couple of cameras running
and saying do the script but then do
some bits around it i love that way of
shooting this allows the show to be more
comedic and lighten the tone in sections
of the show an example of improvisation
and succession came during season one
with logan's birthday meal with adam
mckay revealing that the scene was
completely improvised while the cast
apparently pushed back a little bit over
a scene being fully improvised in the
end they ultimately crushed it and it
added the organic feel that mckay was
looking for let's raise a toast another
example of the scene being improvised
was kendall's violent breakdown in the
show's pilot actor jeremy strong who is
an extreme method actor but more on that
later credited mckay for the scene and
allowing him to follow the character's
instincts saying i had some structural
things in mind in terms of where i might
start and i asked the prop master to
place certain objects in the room
without telling me where they were we
did one take and i followed the line of
intuition throughout the show kendall
and shiv's costume changes reflect where
they are in the show's arc shiv's
outfits become much more corporate as
the show goes on while kendall's suits
often reflect his emotional state such
as his dark suit in the season two
finale as he turns the tables on his
family in a thrilling press conference
however roman's outfits always remain
the same with him often wearing lighter
suits that often reflect that of a
typical tv villain he's also more sloppy
in terms of his dress sense as opposed
to his other family members often going
beltless to show that he is much more
carefree well continuing with the
clothes steam while his children often
wear fashionable tight-fitting suits
logan often wears softer more
loose-fitting clothing to signify that
he has past this prime and a little more
vulnerable than he once was well that's
one interpretation of his outfits anyway
another is that he is so comfortable as
top dog that his clothing reflects his
state of mind and seeing as he's still
screwing everybody over i feel like that
could be the correct interpretation
and lastly on the clothes theme the
subtle difference between the brands
they wear tells you a little more about
the characters themselves take for
instance the sunglasses in the yacht
scene in the episode this is not for
tears in the scene shiv is wearing
traditional ray-bans a sign that she is
loyal to old money rituals and does not
want to be flashy while tom is wearing
pursle a brand that is a little showier
with its celebrity associations in fact
tom's garments are very important to him
and as the outsider he's always trying
to impress with the outfits he wears and
he gets a little bit touchy with shiv
after her and roman teased him on his
boxy suit jeremy strong's relationship
with adam mckay dates back to their time
together on the big short and it was
actually mckay who suggested strong
audition for a role in succession asking
him over lunch which character he would
be most interested in however strong
didn't initially connect with the
character of kendall but instead the
character of roman and originally
auditioned for the role before it went
to the brother of macaulay culkin kieran
culkin but strong got another bite of
the cherry and was asked back to
audition for the role of kendall a
character strong eventually connected
with as the scrappy underdog fueled by
past motivations the audition didn't
originally go very well until strong
eventually turned up the gears and was
given the role on the spot on the other
side of the coin kieran culkin was
actually given the script for the role
of cousin greg but found himself
connecting more with the role of roman
saying there was something that clicked
with me in this character that's
something i still don't understand and
probably don't want to understand
considering the kind of guy he is as we
mentioned though jeremy strong is a
serious method actor and an infamous
profile on him by the new yorker led to
the likes of aaron sorkin and jessica
chastain defending the actors process
strong would apparently remain in the
character's costume when the cameras
weren't rolling go into the makeup tent
by himself to make sure that he wasn't
interacting with his co-stars remain in
character on set and even ended up
hurting his tibia femur and fracturing
his foot while playing the role strong
has said that he channels a lot of
himself into the character and blurs the
line between where he begins and where
kendall ends some of his co-stars such
as brian cox who is a classically
trained actor have voiced concerns over
strong's approach saying the result that
jeremy gets is always pretty tremendous
i just worry about what he does to
himself i worry about the crises he puts
himself through in order to prepare
whatever the process you can't argue
with the results speaking of i'm
talking about the actor get your mind
out of the gutter it was actually the
actor's suggestion that the character of
logan be born in scotland in his
hometown of dundee however the producers
initially rejected this opting instead
to have the character's birthplace be
quebec canada but eventually changed it
to dundee as the show progressed just
saying it should have been aberdeen
that's a peep show reference now a lot
of people have drawn connections between
the roys and the real-life media moguls
the murdochs but jesse armstrong has
categorically denied that the roys are
solely based on the family in fact the
inspiration behind the family is an
amalgamation of the murdochs the
redstones and the hearsts however one
thing that was influenced by the
murdochs was the roy holmes set
decorator george detitta jr said that he
did some research online of the murdoch
media offices to get inspiration for how
to design the one seen in the show oh
and quickly speaking of the murdochs
elizabeth murdock is apparently a fan of
the show and relates to the character of
shiv
as you know new york city is essential
to the show and is a character in its
own right so unsurprisingly the show is
actually shot there logan roy's nyc
apartment is on billionaire's row and
some of the scenes are actually shot
there for the views and it belongs to a
real-life billionaire although the
interior is fake and recorded on
soundstage waystar royco is actually
located in the tallest building in nyc
the one world trade center and although
most scenes are also filmed on a sound
stage some are filmed in the building
for the unique views it provides however
the props seen in these fancy buildings
were actually sourced from outside of
nyc with set decorator george ditto jr
saying that he sourced high-end antiques
from newell props first dibs john street
antiques and a number of antique stores
in westport and stamford connecticut to
give the set an authentic feel while
strong throws himself deep into the
character of kendall when asked which
actor is most like their on-screen
character the cast emphatically agreed
that nicholas brawn is almost exactly
like greg and is the most similar to his
character however when talking about the
influence of greg braun said that he was
partly inspired by a guest he noticed at
a wedding and his awkward dancing braun
said he was just recklessly himself on
the dance floor not judging himself for
it at all not embarrassed and
everybody's looking at him and being
like what the hell i thought there's a
part of greg that's like this guy he can
really enjoy fearlessly this world
as we mentioned earlier the locations of
succession are extremely impressive and
while it takes place for the most part
in new york they have traveled to
various luxurious locations across the
globe one such venue was eastner castle
in herefordshire england where the show
shot for real for shiv's wedding while
king lear oedipus and gatsby might be
some understandable influences on the
show the most surprising influencer is
former president bill clinton apparently
after meeting at a party in the hamptons
clinton reportedly pitched actor
nicholas braun a ton of great ideas for
the show how many were used is unclear
but i mean the guy's a published author
now we can't imagine the show without
him but apparently the roy patriarch
logan was actually supposed to die in
season 1. the show's creators were
planning on killing loganoff and letting
his offspring battle it out in the void
left by him but after having discussions
with the actor they decided to
thankfully keep him around for the long
haul for the twist in the season one
finale armstrong decided to use a piece
of u.s history for reference taking off
of the fatal 1968 car accident ted
kennedy was involved in which resulted
in the death of mary jo kopechny the
other person in the car with him now
this one goes out to all you x-men fans
out there while many people will be
aware that brian cox played the role of
william stryker in x2 he isn't the only
succession actor to have played the role
danny houston who appears in the second
season of the show also played striker
at a different age in x-men origins
wolverine roughly around 20 years before
the events of x2 your country needs you
i'm canadian
back on the subject of locations now
outside of their nyc homes logan roy
also has a summer home in the hamptons
the real location of this house is
actually in the hamptons and it was an
estate built for henry ford's grandson
in the 1960s and finally while he may
play his father on the show brian cox
who was born in 1946 is actually only 10
years older than alan rock who was born
in 1956 who plays his son connor it's
like sean connery and harrison ford in
the last crusade all over again
[Music]